AINSLEY: WE’VE BEEN SHOWING YOU
IMAGES OF PARTYERS OF IN SPRING
BREAK IN FLORIDA.
STEVE: AT LEAST 20 PEOPLE IN
THAT PICTURE BUT NOW SEEMS THE
PARTY MAY BE OVER AS BARS AND
RESTAURANTS ARE CLOSED AND SOME
CITIES HAVE DECIDED TO CLOSE
THEIR BEACHES.
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS
JOINS US RIGHT NOW FROM
TALLAHASSEE, GOVERNOR, GOOD
MORNING TO YOU.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: THOSE IMAGES ARE
DISTURBING BECAUSE THE CDC SAYS
NO GROUP MORE THAN TEN AND YOU
SEE THE STUFF AND I UNDERSTAND
CLEARWATER BEACH, NAPLES HAVE
DECIDED TO CLOSE THEIR BEACHES
TO -- TO GROUPS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME YOU’RE NOT CLOSING THE
STATE BEACHES TO GROUPS OF LESS
THAN 10, RIGHT?
>> SO THE MESSAGE I THINK FOR
SPRING BREAKERS IS THE PARTY IS
OVER IN FLORIDA, YOU’RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CONGREGATE
ON ANY BEACH IN THE STATE.
MANY OF THE HOT SPOTS THAT
PEOPLE LIKE TO GO TO WHETHER
IT’S MIAMI BEACH, FT. LAUDERDALE
AND CLEARWATER, MAYBE COME BACK
NEXT YEAR BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT WE
ARE LOOKING FOR IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
EVERY SINGLE BEACH WILL HAVE TO
ABIDE BY CDC GUIDELINES, NOT
EVERY BEACH WILL REMAIN OPEN BUT
SOME WITH.
WE HAVE SHERIFF’S DEPUTY IN
BREVARD COUNTY OUT ON ATV’S
MAKING SURE THERE’S NO GROUPS.
THAT’S A GOOD APPROACH.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT THE
IMAGES ON CLEARWATER WAS FROM
THE SATURDAY.
AT THAT POINT THE CDC GUIDANCE
WAS GROUPS OF 250 AND MORE AND
ON SUNDAY THEY CHANGED TO 50 AND
THEN ON MONDAY THEY CHANGED IT
TO 10 AND SO AT THAT POINT,
OKAY, WE NEED TO STARE CLEAR OF
ANY LARGE GROUPS SO WE DID IT
FOR THE BEACHES AND THEN WE DID
IT FOR THE BARS AND CLOSED THE
BARS DOWN AND I ALSO WOULD SAY
THIS, WE ARE SEEING MASSIVE
CANCELLATIONS.
SOME WERE PICTURES OF PEOPLE
THAT STARTED GOING DOWN HERE AND
A LOT OF THE STUFF YOU WILL SEE
A LOT FEWER PEOPLE COMING TO
FLORIDA RIGHT NOW.
THE NUMBERS ARE OFF THE CHARTS
IN TERMS OF CANCELLATIONS.
AINSLEY: SO GLAD THAT YOU CAME
ONTO EXPLAIN THAT.
I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO CRITICS THAT SAY YOU
SHOULD HAVE DONE IT A LOT
SOONER.
ALL OF THOSE WERE CANCELED.
I WAS READING A STORY THAT
CLEARWATER IS NOT CLOSING
BEACHES UNTIL MONDAY.
>> RIGHT, SO THEY HAVE TO MAKE
THEIR DECISIONS AS TO HOW THEY
SEE IT BUT REGARDLESS OF LOCAL
DECISIONS, YOU’RE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO CONGREGATE LIKE THOSE
IMAGES THAT YOU SAW.
THAT’S JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE GOING TO ALLOW AND SO YOU
WANT TO WORK CONSTRUCTIVELY WITH
THE LOCALS TO GET THE BEST
SOLUTIONS BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE THE TYPES OF
CANCELLATIONS, THAT’S GOING TO
HAVE A MAJOR AFFECT ON WORKERS
IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE PRIOR TO
THIS GOT TO 2.8%.
I MEAN, JUST WE ARE -- ECONOMY
WAS HUMMING, THINGS WERE GOING
ALONG GREAT AND NOW THE EXTERNAL
EVENT, THE VIRUS WILL DISLOCATE
A LOT OF PEOPLE AND SO WE ARE
VERY MINDFUL OF THAT AND WE ARE
WORKING HARD TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THEM JUST AS WE WORK TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT OUR CITIZENS
FROM THE VIRUS.
STEVE: SURE, WHEN YOU TALK TO
THE PRESIDENT AND THE WHITE
HOUSE TEAM, WHAT DO YOU TELL
THEM YOUR MAIN CONCERN IS?
>> FOR US IT’S JUST SUPPLIES.
I MEAN, WE’VE RAMPED UP TESTING
BUT I NEED MORE SWABS, I NEED
MORE OF THE REAGENTS, IF WE HAVE
THAT, WE COULD DRAMATICALLY
EXPAND THE TESTING AND I THINK
THAT WILL REALLY HELP US BECAUSE
PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH SOME OF
THE STUFF THAT WE’VE BEEN DOING
AND I DON’T QUARREL WITH IT,
IT’S NOT REALLY BASED ON DATA IN
OUR COUNTRY.
IT’S MORE BASED ON MODELING.
WHEN YOU GET THE MORE TEST IN
THERE LIKE SOUTH KOREA DID,
YOU’RE ABLE TO ISOLATE CASES AND
FIGURE OUT WHERE THE PROBLEM IS
AND HAVE NICE TARGETED SOLUTION.
THAT’S THE NUMBER 1.
THE PPE, THE SWABS, THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT GO INTO
TESTING, THE MORE WE CAN GET OF
THOSE, WE CAN GET INTO A GROUP
HERE AND I THINK WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
PREVENT THIS VIRUS FROM
SPREADING TO THE EXTENT IT HAS.
AINSLEY: YOU HAVE A LOT OF SNOW
BIRDS THAT WILL STAY THERE, BUT
A LOT OF OUR FRIENDS CANCELED
THEIR TRIPS TO BAHAMAS, EUROPE,
WHATEVER, AND THEY ALL ENDED UP
IN FLORIDA.
I HOPE THEY DIDN’T CARRY IT DOWN
THERE.
GOD BLESS YOU.
>> WELL, PEOPLE ARE BEING
MINDFUL.
FOLKS ARE TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY
AND WE THANK THEM PARTICULARLY
OUR SENIOR CITIZENS.
AINSLEY: YEAH.